it might seem like magic you feel bad
you take a pill and within a couple
hours you'll notice relief from your
headache swollen knee or heartburn but
what happened between taking the drug
and feeling better
it certainly wasn't magic although the
way it works in your body is pretty
amazing
I'm gonna use the word drug a lot to
talk about medicine now this might bring
to mind some negative association but I
encourage you to have an open mind when
it comes to this word sure drugs can
refer to legal and illegal substances
that people abuse but the first
definition in the oxford living
dictionary is a medicine or other
substance which has a physiological
effect when ingested or otherwise
introduced into the body this means that
in addition to prescribed medicine any
food or herb you take in a medicinal way
is a drug so if you're regularly using
turmeric st. John's war or central oils
for their medicinal properties you're
using them as drugs and you probably
should talk to your doctor about it ok
enough definitions let's talk about the
journey a drug takes through your body
to carry out its therapeutic effect when
you swallow a pill it travels into your
stomach where it'll start to break down
if the pill is a tablet or capsule the
active ingredient is mixed with many
other inactive chemicals to help it
along its way there are chemical
compounds that allow the drug to be
compressed into a tablet others that
make the pill big enough to swallow
compounds that prevent it from sticking
to the lining of your digestive system
and molecules that help it to break up
at just the right time the stomach is a
harsh environment it's really acidic and
filled with proteins called enzymes that
break down the nutrients in our food to
produce energy the chemical bonds that
make up the foods we eat are
surprisingly similar to those in a
medicinal compound so some of the drug
might be degraded in the stomach certain
drugs depending on their chemical
properties could theoretically absorb
through the stomach cells and into your
body but that's kind of difficult the
drug doesn't spend that much time in the
stomach the surface area is small
compared to the twisting convoluted
intestine and there's a protective layer
of mucus on the inside of the stomach
that prevents the acid inside from
digesting the stomach itself all of
these things impede absorption also a
lot of drugs especially those affecting
the brain can react reversibly with
the acid in the stomach and become
charged in that low pH environment if
the drug is going to pass through the
lining of the digestive system it is
best if it is not charged this is
because the lining of the digestive
tract is made up of a cell type called
epithelial cells which are surrounded by
a greasy membrane the composition of the
innermost part of the lining is rather
similar to cooking oil now salt which is
made up of charged components doesn't
dissolve in my oil compounds need to be
similar to mix oil and water don't mix
because they are dissimilar but oil and
butter do because they're both greasy
you can remember this concept with the
phrase like dissolves like if something
is charged it's harder for it to
interact with the greasy lining of the
cells and pass through them but once a
drug moves into the less acidic higher
pH environment of the intestine it
becomes uncharged and can absorb by what
we call passive diffusion other drugs
can actually fool a transporter protein
that is used by vitamins or nutrients to
make its way through the cells of the
intestinal lining by a process called
active transport now before it can make
its way into the bloodstream an orally
administered drug encounters the liver
the liver contains lots of enzymes that
can do things like add oxygen atoms onto
the molecule this liver metabolism is
called first pass and can sometimes
inactivate a drug completely if this
happens the drug cannot be administered
orally and may need to be taken
intravenously or sublingually adding
oxygen atoms onto molecules is a great
way to make them even more water-soluble
and we say that the addition of oxygen
makes a compound more polar very polar
compounds are readily eliminated by the
kidneys in the urine so these reactions
are nature's way of protecting the body
from foreign compound the portion of the
drug that has not been lost in the
absorption process or destroyed by
enzymes can make its way into the
bloodstream where it is quickly
delivered widely to cells throughout the
body but a well-designed drug will
only work where it's needed and doesn't
do anything where it's not needed the
vast majority of drugs are going to
interact in some way with a protein to
carry out their therapeutic effect
proteins are long chains of amino acids
synthesized in your body
the chains fold up into a
three-dimensional shape that's critical
to its function some proteins even fold
in such a way that the amino acids they
are made of can promote chemical
reactions and they can do the reactions
faster than we ever could do in the lab
billions and billions of reactions a
second these proteins are called enzymes
and they carry out the chemical
reactions that are constantly going on
in your body
to turn your food into energy build your
DNA store sugar make hormones and
countless other vital processes that
keep us alive and healthy receptors are
another very common drug target these
are proteins either located on the
surface of cells or within the cells on
the surface of the nucleus binding of a
drug to a receptor can either turn on or
turn off a process in the cell let's
look at a quick example of how an enzyme
can be regulated by a drug most often
drugs are used to turn off enzyme
reactions they do this by binding the
enzyme interacting with it in such a way
that prevents the usual chemical
reaction in a process called inhibition
imagine you twist your Nina swells
inflammation is a good thing here the
process brings in cells that can heal
the tissue
however inflammation can also play a
role in chronic disease there are many
factors that contribute to the complex
inflammation process but one of the
significant ones are molecules called
prostaglandins when you have an injury
your body will respond by producing more
enzymes that make prostaglandins if
you're swelling persists too long your
doctor might tell you to take an
anti-inflammatory like aspirin or
ibuprofen these molecules fit in to the
spot of the enzyme where the
prostaglandin forming reaction usually
occurs block it from happening and
inflammation is reduced now a drug
doesn't just stay
active in your body forever just like in
the liver your body is constantly trying
to protect you by eliminating foreign
substances remember those enzymes that
add oxygen to molecules and help them be
eliminated well those are found
throughout the body and there are other
enzymes that enable the drug to react in
different ways all of which make it more
polar and more water-soluble when the
drug is moving around through your body
enzymes are reacting with it once a
reaction occurs that changes the drug
into an inactive metabolite its effect
in the body stops once enough polar
groups are added to the molecule the
drug passes rapidly to the kidneys where
it is excreted in the urine the time it
takes for half of the drug to be
excreted is called the half-life of the
drug and the frequency at which you're
prescribed a drug is related to the
half-life for example a drug with a
12-hour half-life may need to be
administered twice a day the journey of
a drug through the body is a complicated
process but if a drug is designed well
enough of it will make it to your cells
where it can interact with proteins to
treat ailments and disease as you might
imagine it takes a lot of work to
carefully design a pill that will let a
drug molecule be absorbed survive in the
body reach its target and make you
better
fortunately teams of talented scientists
are working on these problems every day
to improve your health this video is the
first in a series about medicine
dedicated to my mom if you enjoy
learning about how medicines work in
your body subscribe to my channel and if
you'd like to see anything in particular
leave me a message in the comments
[Music]